we've been covering for you for months
now the most transparent administration
in American history which stopped for 41
days giving press briefings altogether
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is Donald Trump's
press secretary and she has been giving
fewer and fewer press briefings over
time and up until yesterday it had been
41 days since the last one and all of
the normal stuff that we've become
accustomed to at these gongshow press
briefings took place and I wouldn't be
shocked if we don't hear from her again
for a very very long time not answering
questions blaming Democrats for
everything and generally speaking making
a fool out of herself coming out and
speaking after I think it was Steven
minuchin and Larry Kudlow and maybe one
other person who spoke before her
speaking to the press out comes Sarah
Huckabee Sanders starts getting asked
very reasonable questions like for
example we have this three-week stopgap
measure which reopen government Trump
had no money for the wall does Trump
want another shutdown starting on
February 15th and her answer is it's the
fault of Democrats is the president
really willing to go through another
shutdown if you can't get any money
handed to Democrats for the boardwalk
the president doesn't want to go through
another shutdown that's not the goal the
goal is were security I'm protecting the
American people
ideally Democrats would take these next
three weeks to negotiate in good faith
as they've indicated that they would and
come up with a deal that makes sense
that actually fixes the problem
so we don't have to go through that
process so what she's saying is Trump
had the house and the Senate for two
years during a supposed at immigration
crisis that was going on then because it
was worse than the now if it's a crisis
now it had to have been a crisis then
did nothing to build the wall Democrats
take the house back and now Trump says
either Democrats fix this problem or I
shut down the government it's absolute
and total joke it's a farce next
question the stuff that Trump offered to
Democrats in that second crazy
immigration speech remember
when he said I will do 3 years of
extension on daca recipient status I
will do 3 years
extension on TPS temporary protected
status reasonable question from the from
the press is that still on the table
Trump offered it is it still on the
table for Democrats
Sarah Huckabee Sanders won't say maybe
this immigration speech are though still
on the table look I'm not going to
negotiate here that's why they have the
conference's for congressional members
to work through some of those things to
come back to the president with the deal
the president has laid out things in the
past that he's willing to do we'll see
what they come back with but what I do
know is if they don't come back with a
deal that means Democrats get virtually
nothing
so first answer was it's the fault of
Democrats and they need to fix this then
the question is is Trump's offer still
on the table she won't say but she again
says it's up to Democrats to figure this
out or they get nothing and then it gets
brilliant in the sense of being evil
genius
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is asked why did
Trump hire undocumented immigrants at
his businesses and of course there is no
good answer for that other than to just
tell the truth which is this is what
companies do people like Trump and
corporations hire undocumented
immigrants and they don't get in trouble
so obviously they're going to keep
hiring undocumented immigrants check out
what she says truly orwellian described
immigration as a peerless threat and
they said they're taking American
workers jobs you explain why the
president hired and employed as so many
undocumented we're going to this club
for years that didn't do more to prevent
them from staying employed and working
there look I can't get into specifics
about the president's organization
outside of the White House I'm only
allowed to speak on behalf of the
president in his official capacity I do
know that the Trump Organization has put
out a statement addressing that issue I
would refer you to that into them for
further questions
president I think should happen to a
business that you know employs illegal
immigrants and doesn't use systems to
check and make sure that I do it laughs
that's one of the reasons that the
president wants to actually fix the
problem he's one of the people that's
identified the fact that we have a
problem and we should fix our
immigration system if Democrats want to
get serious about fixing that they have
a president that's more than happy to
sit down with them and do exactly that
yeah hey the president's company hired
undocumented immigrants what about that
in what should happen to those companies
listen Trump identified this problem
I guess she means by being part of the
problem and if Democrats want to fix it
then Democrats can fix it and he'll
allow them to do that it's evil genius
it's just uh it's it's completely vapid
in every sense and I need to
congratulate CNN and MSNBC they didn't
air this ok Fox News ran the press
briefing live CNN and MSNBC just stuck
to the regular programming and I've been
saying for a while
if you can't fact check it live since
it's so wild run it later condensed with
fact-checking even do a five-minute
delay so you can do fact checking on on
screen I think that there's more going
on here then she's just a liar and an
obfuscator I actually think part of the
reason she's not answering questions is
I don't know that Trump is really
speaking to Sarah Huckabee Sanders
anymore I actually think she doesn't
know what Trump is thinking and what
from positions are on a lot of these
issues and remember we were told the
most transparent administration in
history that ship has certainly long
sailed let me know your thoughts about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show okay
if we want to take advantage of having
data to figure out whether a particular
policy has succeeded or failed we need
two things or I guess you could say we
need at least two things we need time to
allow that policy to either succeed or
fail or maybe do neither but we also
need to know what to measure right just
having data
isn't useful unless we know what are we
looking for what would be a sign that a
policy has succeeded or failed we can
now apply this a sort of paradigm this
infrastructure to look at Donald Trump's
tax cuts and I say that with some
reservation because it wasn't actually a
tax cut for everyone and even some of
the people who did get a tax cut in the
short term it's not a permanent tax cut
but I think you know what I'm talking
about when I say the Trump quote tax
cuts so we've had some time it's been a
little while now we're starting to get a
sense of the effect but what should we
measure to figure out whether the tax
cuts have been successful or not well I
think the most relevant way to do this
would be to look at what Donald Trump
claimed would be the effect of the tax
cuts and see if it was and the big
picture was that the tax cuts will
reduce government revenue in a sort of
short-term micro way but they are going
to cause the economy to grow so much the
economy is going to be on fire that the
tax cuts will pay for themselves and
will reduce the deficit overall so tax
cuts go down so government revenue goes
down but the tax cuts that rich people
and corporations get gets put right back
into the economy and it will trickle
down and generate so much new income and
productivity that government revenues
will actually go up and then they can
reduce the deficit and start paying off
the debt this hasn't happened okay to
make it very short for you we have a new
report from the National Association of
Business Economics 84 percent of
respondents businesses have not changed
plans as a result of the corporate tax
cut seventy five percent say they have
not nor do they have plans to increase
hiring so think about that for a second
corporate tax rate goes from 35 percent
to 21 percent that's a 40 percent cut
okay going from 35 to 21 is a 40 percent
decrease in the corporate tax rate
eighty-four percent of businesses make
no change to their capital investment at
all the other 16 are either increasing
or summer decreasing capital investment
remember the other 16 aren't all
increasing capital investment
those who are increasing capital
investment and are increasing hiring
need to now make up for a 40% reduction
to the corporate tax rate to make this
tax plan deficit negative meaning that
it reduces the deficit obviously it
wouldn't I mean just think about this at
the most basic level if I'm a business
owner and I get a tax cut nothing else
changes why do I hire people right why
do I go and choose to increase my
operating costs by adding employees
because I got a tax cut I would hire
more employees if there's more demand
for my product or service if I have the
staff to make a hundred widgets and the
demand for my widgets is at a hundred
widgets why would I go in hire people to
be able to make 200 widgets that would
be a really dumb move if all of a sudden
the demand for my product goes up to 200
widgets now I have a reason to go and
hire employees in order to be able to
accommodate that increased demand if I
get a tax cut and nobody wants more of
my widgets it would be stupid to hire
more people and the proof is in the
deficit numbers we were told this would
be so good for the economy that we would
start to cut away at the deficit we
might even start to pay off that
national debt if we ever got to a
surplus and it's all nonsense the
reality is that we learned this week
that the US Treasury is going to have to
maintain this increased level of
borrowing planning more than 1 trillion
dollars in borrowing for the second
straight year and it's partially because
of Trump's tax cuts it's partially
because of other policies all of which
are increasing the deficit you can argue
we shouldn't be so worried about the
deficit and I would agree with you but
again we are evaluating the policy on
the basis of what Trump said it would do
it's completely predictable and it plays
right into China's hands because to
finance this deficit we are selling long
term
yet called 310 and 30-year securities
who is a big buyer of these securities
it's China Trump told us he was going to
take back control of our economy from
China and instead China and other
countries are buying our debt so that we
can finance our government operations
despite increasing deficits which Trump
told us that he would reduce it is
lose-lose-lose
and the crazy thing about this Pat is
that we knew it would happen our own
government the Congressional Budget
Office told us this is exactly what's
going to happen we knew it would happen
serious economists knew it would happen
and they either didn't care or didn't
believe it and as usual the estimates
were right do you think they even care
about this reality or have they moved on
to something else Pat I would go even
further and say that from the get-go
they knew that this wasn't going to work
that the tax cuts wouldn't just spur so
much economic growth that they would pay
for themselves I think that they weren't
arguing a good faith they just wanted to
serve their donors they want to serve
their corporate overlords and when you
think about what Trump was able to get
done legislatively in his first two
years it wasn't much she was pretty much
impotent he couldn't he couldn't repeal
Obamacare
he couldn't get his wall built but yet
again he was able to get the tax cuts
passed and I think that's really telling
the normal but but but David responses
here are going to be but David what
about X company which is hiring more
people well lots of companies are firing
and not hiring despite getting tax cuts
but more importantly if the tax cuts
objectively created hiring more than
just anecdotally you would see most
companies hiring more people and hiring
depends a lot on the underlying economic
conditions which have been good for
years although they're now slowing down
but David what about X company which
gave people raises lots of companies
give raises periodically anyway others
are announcing them but are phasing them
in over multiple years many of them
would be giving raises regardless of tax
cuts what matters here is the aggregate
not individual anecdotal stories that we
can tell and the aggregate is just not
good for these tax cuts and every every
month we
more and more data to support that a
congressman is now formally publicly
saying he believes the current President
of the United States is a Russian agent
and I'm gonna talk about the use of the
word agent in a second because that's
important here so let's back up a moment
we had this FBI probe into whether
Donald Trump is a Russian asset and that
was opened pretty early on in Donald
Trump's presidency we talked about that
I believe it was at the beginning of
last week if not the previous week and
part of what we learned based on the
reporting of the New York Times on this
issue is that the FBI was worried about
Trump being a Russian asset pretty early
on in his campaign but they weren't sure
how they could open up an investigation
into that without the political
repercussions of it that might take
place but once Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey to interfere in the
Russia investigation the FBI felt that
this has crossed a line where now we
have more than enough cover to start
investigating Trump as a Russian asset
now I've said before I believe Russian
agent is simply not the right word here
okay I've seen no serious suggestion
that Trump is a Russian agent an agent
would be like an intelligence agent of
Russia or something much more formal
asset is a broader term asset could mean
Trump's compromised and under the
influence of Russia for example it could
mean that he has been influenced in a
way that he's not even aware of as as
making him an asset but in a way that
makes him useful to Russian interests as
someone in power in the United States in
any case I believe the right word would
be is he an asset not an agent
but Democratic congressman Eric's wall
well from California is now saying
publicly in interviews that he believes
Trump is a Russian agent check out this
video from an interview he did with
Margaret Hoover at what point you draw
the line and not accused the president
United States without any evidence of
being an agent of Russia yeah he's
betrayed our country and I don't I don't
say that lightly I worked as a
prosecutor for seven years and I
betraying the country by the way we want
evidence before you say that but you
said an agent of Russia yeah he he works
on their behalf he since he met with
Vladimir Putin in Helsinki in July where
he took the interpreters no service
hasn't told any US official what they
discussed
he has taken us out of Syria which is a
top priority of Russia
he sought diminish or pullout the u.s.
from NATO and he's easing sanctions on
Vladimir Putin's friends who are under
investigation past sanctions against
Russia
he has armed Ukraine he has killed 200
Russians in Syria I mean those aren't
the actions of an agent of Russia either
he signed I think you know but
grudgingly sanctions against Russia
after Congress and people expressed
concern and he got backed into it but as
soon as he could he has pulled those
away and so what makes him an agent of
Russia sorry during the campaign the
Russians were offering and we saw this
in our investigation and Free Press
report and show this they were offering
their assistance to help him they were
reaching out you know whether it was the
Trump Tower meeting whether it was you
know the number of subject line emails
we saw that said you know Russia Putin
Trump let's connect them whether it was
trying to build a Trump Tower and say in
Felix Seder a Russian American who
worked for president Trump saying if we
connect Vladimir Putin and Donald Trump
we can engineer this and make our boy
president he never turned down those
offers in fact after it was revealed
that the Russians were attacking our
democracy he went to a press conference
and said Russia keep doing it so won't
work so there's a lot in there
sois well says Russian agent but what
he's describing is actually a Russian
asset again so I think it's a tactical
mistake to use the wrong word because
now swallow is going to get absolutely
crushed about that because again Trump
is not a Russian agent that doesn't make
sense based on what we know he's a
Russian asset if anything and that is
the word that really should be used but
when I watch this Pat what I see is
Eric's wall well a guy who's on the
House Intelligence Committee who knows a
ton of stuff that is not public I see a
guy who has come to his conclusion that
Trump is a Russian asset on the basis of
stuff that he has seen behind closed
doors and he is trying very hard to make
a case for that only with what is okay
to say publicly and that that's what I
see here this is not a guy who by virtue
of his role on the house Intel committee
is going to make this allegation if he
doesn't think he has the evidence to
back
it's just that he can't really make the
case publicly because so much of what
he's seen is not public at this time
that very well may be the case but given
the fact that he can't offer up that
information I think it makes it fall
flat because it's gonna say that the guy
is a Russian agent I think you have to
present some supporting evidence to that
effect if you're gonna go on TV and
spout that and I think at the end of the
day these words do matter
same thing when when Democrats like
Bernie Sanders and Alexandria of Casco
Cortez go out there and say that their
Democratic socialists when they're
actually Social Democrats I think I
think you're just opening yourself up to
criticism and it's completely an
unforced error I think it would have
been smarter for sois well first of all
to say Russian asset and not agent and
to say listen I am privy to a lot of
classified information because of my
role and I can't actually talk about
that right now but where was the
evidence when Donald Trump claimed
Hillary Clinton committed crimes which
should put her in prison where was the
evidence when Donald Trump claimed that
Obama spied on him where was the
evidence that Obama wasn't born in the
United States when Donald Trump was
claiming that since when has evidence
been required to make outrageous claims
I actually happened to have knowledge
here you will find out of it into it
find out about it in due course or
something like that and most importantly
he really should have said asset and not
agent because agent has one meaning an
asset has another meaning and I've seen
nothing to suggest that Donald Trump is
a Russian agent so certainly at minimum
a tactical mistake by Eric's wall well
but hopefully at some point we'll know
why he's come to that conclusion every
time I tell you how lazy Donald Trump is
and how little work he's doing how long
he's spending at his golf clubs and on
the golf course how long he is spending
watching TV and how he never reads it's
sort of a mixed bag because on the one
hand obviously I don't want a lazy piece
of crap president I want somebody who
does things and reads things and is
informed and studies issues deeply
something that I just have seen no
evidence Donald Trump is actually
capable of on the other hand though
there is this sense in which like the
less Trump does maybe the better off we
are
but according to a new report Donald
Trump has receded even further into this
never-ending sight cycle or circle of
watching fox news and eating and
tweeting because as of yesterday morning
Donald Trump has had nothing nothing on
his schedule all week other than lunch
with Mike Pence one day and his
presidential daily briefing which for
most presidents is an extensive meeting
with our intelligence community after
having read a bunch of stuff on paper
and studied other issues related to it
the night before for Trump the PDB the
presidential daily briefing has been
reduced to a single page mostly pictures
and charts and graphs with a couple of
bullet points that's all that Donald
Trump has had on his schedule and
reportedly that PDB did not go well
yesterday morning Trump reportedly
reaming out dan coates the Director of
National Intelligence so what else is
Trump doing is Trump spending so much
time on the phone
negotiating great deals that he needs
his schedule to be completely clear is
he involved in more secret talks with
Vladimir Putin of which there are going
to be no records whatsoever is he about
ready to get Mexico to pay for the wall
and it's taking up time is he preparing
for Black History Month which starts on
February 1st somehow I don't think so
or is he just lazy and doing nothing and
worried about the storm cloud of
criminality that is closer and closer to
completely enveloping him now you would
be completely appropriate if you said
we'll hold on David what did a day out
of President Obama's schedule look like
just to compare very good question I
took a look I picked a random day out of
President Obama's schedule and what
you'll realize is that President Obama
had a very different schedule than Trump
for example at 9:30 a.m. this was by the
way after President Obama would get up
and either exercise or read neither
activity one that Donald Trump partakes
in 9:30 a.m. president and vice
president received the presidential
daily briefing 10:00 a.m. income the
senior advisors to the president 10:30
a.m. president goes directly into a
cabin
meeting 1215 the president and vice
president meet for lunch privately at
1:30 the president meets with members of
the Technology CEO council at 4:30 the
president and vice president have a
meeting with Secretary of Defense gates
even though they already had the
presidential daily briefing at first
9:30 in the morning
6:20 p.m. the president delivers remarks
on the situation in Egypt and then of
course we know that President Obama
would then go to the residence and read
up documents briefings books nonfiction
fiction so there's a very clear
difference here Pat the only question is
are we better off the less Trump does ah
that's a good question I've never been
able to get a conclusive answer on that
and I would just say that being lazy
every now and then that's all well and
good it's nice to veg out like I'm going
on vacation next week for example and
I'm looking forward to it but I'm not
the president I think when you decide to
run for president and you get elected
you have to be able to invest that four
year period and work as hard as you can
only take a little bit of time off here
and there and even then you're getting
working vacations you have to be able to
be committed to the job and Trump just
isn't yeah there's a couple of other
elements here as well which is that this
didn't just sneak up on Trump Trump
actually said I'm gonna be so busy I'm
not going to be leaving the White House
there's not going to be any golfing or
anything like that he said setting
records for how much he golf's and if we
look at Trump's tweets this week they're
seeming like kind of extra flaccid and
weak and I think that there may be
something just more generally going on
with him check out this example Trump
tweeted yesterday if the committee of
Republicans and Democrats now meeting on
border security is not discussing or
contemplating a wall or physical barrier
they are wasting their time yeah all
right okay
you've said that before and it's pretty
boring and it doesn't really seem to
have any power behind it now that you
completely lost the shutdown so my
question to the audience is as follows
should we be critical of this lazy
imposter president or should we be glad
that he's not actually doing things
since what he does is
bad for the country and for the world a
lot of people wrote to me saying yeah
the less involved Trump is the better
off everyone is but I don't think it's
that simple and the reason why is Trump
told us he was going to hire the best
people obviously that hasn't happened
even when Trump is just watching Fox and
Friends those horrible cabinet members
and staffers are still out there
damaging the world it's really a
double-edged sword and I could sort of
see it from both sides but what we do
know for sure is the guy's barely doing
a damn thing in the middle of all the
craziness of the last couple days
this next story really didn't get the
attention that it deserves
Donald Trump has this interim attorney
general Matthew Whitaker this is the guy
I've previously told you said that only
Christians should be federal judges this
is the guy who in the past has outlined
as a private citizen of course exactly
how he would interfere with the Trump
Russia probe if given the chance and he
gave a couple of days ago a bizarre and
confused and I guess rambling would be
the other adjective I would apply to it
bizarre confused and rambling speech
while sweating profusely and he lets
things slip during this speech that are
really odd so pay very close attention
to what he says which we'll talk about
shortly but also notice both if you're
just listening but also if you're
watching the really strange demeanor and
dynamics of his speech you know I've
been fully briefed on the investigation
and you know I look forward to director
molar delivering the final report and I
really am NOT going to talk about open
and ongoing investigation otherwise but
you know sort of the statements that I
made where as a private citizen only
with publicly available information and
I you know I am I am comfortable that
the decisions that were made are going
to be reviewed
you know either through the various
means we have but right now you know the
investigation is I think close to being
completed and I hope that we can get the
report from director Muller
as soon as we as possible he truly
doesn't seem to know what he's talking
about he doesn't seem to know what he's
saying it seems like one of those
moments where the brain becomes
disconnected from the mouth and things
just come out so when he says he's been
fully briefed on the investigation by
whom and to what degree like what what
exactly is he talking about when he says
he's been fully briefed about the
investigation everything he said before
about how he would end and interfere
with the investigation forget about all
of that stuff he says because those were
comments that he made as a private
citizen but the most disturbing thing
that he said here which again it this is
not getting nearly the attention it
deserves he said that he's comfortable
that the decisions that were made with
regard to the investigation are going to
be reviewed what on earth does that mean
Pat who is going to review them for what
purpose what what is he talking about
what does that even mean well he is
technically Robert Muller's boss that's
the crazy world that we live in so maybe
he has been personally briefed but I
suspect that he hasn't and he's talking
out of as you know what and then he gets
to the investigation is close to being
completed it didn't even really seem
like he was trying to say that he sort
of stuttered in a very strange way we
know that we haven't had any any leaks
from Muller about when the
investigations going to be over would
Muller even considering that yes and
some harebrained and horrible ways Pat
points out Whitaker is Muller's boss
would Muller have said to Matthew
Whitaker that he's almost done is
Whitaker guessing that the investigation
is almost over is he hoping that it's
almost over is he trying to by saying
this publicly push the investigation to
actually and soon Whitakers involvement
in the Justice Department has just been
a train wreck from day one everything
related to the guy is weird and as far
as this investigation ending soon thing
that he said deliberately are not
deliberately truthfully or untruthfully
Whitaker's wife is named Marcie Whitaker
she recently emailed a reporter from
Slate to tell him that his article is
bad and wrong and also to assert that
the Muller
vestigation is wrapping up those were
the words that Marci Whitaker said to a
member of the media that the molar
investigation is wrapping up
how would Mathieu Whitaker's wife know
that even if it's true that's
extraordinarily inappropriate whether
it's true or not
Marcy Whittaker doesn't work in
government she doesn't have a security
clearance so if she's lying and just
emailing reporters that the
investigations going to end when she
actually doesn't know anything about
that that's inappropriate but if Matthew
Whitaker has told his wife things that
aren't available to the public that's
criminal okay just imagine for a second
here if the roles were reversed and it
was I don't know Hillary Clinton
Attorney General and you had her husband
Bill Clinton emailing reporters with
information that was at that point
unknown to the public they would be
calling for her immediate imprisonment
Pat and yet here we have Matthew
Whitaker in way over his head without
the slightest idea what's going on
what's appropriate and as far as the
probe is ending maybe he's right maybe
he's not but there is something very
wrong going on here well the upside is
that Matthew Whitaker will only be the
acting Attorney General for another week
or two the downside is that his
replacement William Barr he expressed
that he's not going to interfere with
the Malheur investigation but Democrats
can't get a straight answer as to
whether he'll release the full report to
the public and that we really got to
know William Barr could be just as bad
yeah this is now becoming the new
question which is okay allowing an
investigation to go on is correct it's
fine it's sort of like a baseline it
shouldn't even be a question as to
whether the Attorney General is going to
interfere with ongoing investigations
but then the question is are we going to
be able to see the results of that
investigation and he has played very
very coy and avoided just giving a
straight answer on that during his
confirmation hearings will the
investigation and soon I don't know I
mean every three to four weeks we see
articles claiming molars almost done and
those articles date all the way back to
almost two years ago in 2017 we know we
haven't seen leaks from Muller I
questioned whether molar would go to
Whitaker and say
I'm about to be done maybe mold or did
do that but on the other hand when I see
that the FBI conducts a pre-dawn raid on
Trump associate Roger stone so that he
can't destroy evidence as the FBI shows
up that doesn't signal to me that the
investigation is close to done it would
strike me as a signal that there's still
work to be done here the truth is we
don't know the reality is there have not
actually been any leaks from Robert
Muller as far as that goes so we'll have
to wait and see but what is very very
clear is that Matthew Whitaker is in way
over his head he doesn't know what he's
talking about
and it's a good thing that he's going to
be out sooner than later then we become
concerned about his replacement and that
really is a problem make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
hackman where i just announced some new
upcoming public speaking engagements
that i will be doing maybe one will be
coming to your city or town or
indoctrinated liberal college campus who
knows follow me on instagram at david
pakman make sure you follow the david
pakman show on instagram also at david
pakman show former NFL football player
Arian Foster joins me next to talk about
is Tom Brady the greatest of all time we
get through that topic very quickly as
my prediction we will also talk about
his leaving religion and becoming an
atheist the National Anthem protests by
football players and much much more
Arian Foster joins me next okay when I
started preparing this story I thought
that the big news that I would be
reporting to you would be plainly that
Roger stone has been arrested and
charged with multiple crimes right it's
another Trump insider who has fallen
getting closer and closer to Donald
Trump himself and that is a huge story
this pre-dawn FBI raid being used
because Robert Muller understandably was
worried that Roger stone would try to
destroy evidence if given the
opportunity but the even bigger story is
that now Roger stone is no longer ruling
out cooperating with Robert Muller this
is the guy stone who was never going to
what the guy that Trump was holding up
as a hero for not cooperating he might
be cooperating check out my interview by
the way with Roger stone which weary
plop republished to the YouTube channel
where of course he denies all wrongdoing
of all kinds no one's going to get him
for anything because he just did nothing
wrong ever obviously that doesn't appear
to have been the case although he is
still obviously innocent until proven
guilty the details here are that he is
being charged for lying to the House
Intelligence Committee about
interactions with WikiLeaks in the 2016
campaign obstruction witness tampering
this series of charges is huge in a few
different ways number one it's more
connections to Russia and that's huge
and stone is right in there with it here
is stone by the way leaving the
courthouse on the day of his arrest to
chance of lock him up from the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
what a show I mean just absolutely
stunning
so more connections to Russia more
chance to lock him up but the real
question now that we know more about how
yeah WikiLeaks was involved in helping
Trump defeat Hillary and yeah stone was
in talks with WikiLeaks and yes Donald
Trump's public statements about document
dumps seemed to correlate really closely
with WikiLeaks suspiciously so the
question now is was Trump really totally
in the dark about the stone connections
to WikiLeaks and therefore to Russia as
I've said before it's very hard to
believe that Trump was in the dark about
the Trump Tower meeting with a Russian
lawyer and it's just as difficult to
believe that he didn't know that
WikiLeaks was helping his campaign so
all of this is huge but then remember
this tweet from last month Donald Trump
tweeting quoting Roger stone I will
never testify against Trump this
statement was recently made by Roger
stone essentially stating that he will
not be forced by a rogue and
out-of-control prosecutor to make up
lies and stories about president Trump
nice to know that some people still have
guts well not so fast because we now
have Roger stone telling George
Stephanopoulos on ABC that he is no
longer ruling out cooperating with
Robert Muller take a look at this you
say you won't bear false witness against
President Trump are you prepared to tell
the truth about your dealings with him
to the special counsel your truth about
your dealings with the campaign any
chance you'll cooperate with special
counsel Robert Muller if he asks you
know that's a question I would have to
do I'd have to determine after my
attorneys have some discussion if
there's wrongdoing by other people in
the campaign that I know about which I
know of none but if there is I would
certainly testify honestly I'd also
testify honestly about any other matter
including any communications with the
president it's true that we spoke on the
phone but those communications are
political in nature they're benign and
there's there isn't certainly no
conspiracy with Russia presidents right
there is no Russia and he's never
suggested to you and
any way shape or form that you that he
might offer you a pardon absolutely
positively not I have never discussed a
pardon the only person that I had
advocated a pardon for as we discussed
previously is a posthumous pardon for
marcus garvey yeah so lots of caveats
lots of ifs and conditionals but that is
not a no I will not cooperate and that's
already a major change from what Donald
Trump at least seemed to believe about
Roger stone as recently as six weeks ago
so there's a few things here ignore the
fact that Roger stone spent 12 minutes
professing his innocence here Trump
tweeted now to distance himself from
Roger stone over the weekend Roger stone
didn't even work for me anywhere near
the election an election of course with
a capital e but that's neither here nor
there so stone understands that he's in
trouble because he's now no longer
ruling out cooperating with Robert
Muller of course to tell the truth if he
knew of anything which he doesn't know
about he probably sees that Trump is
bailing on him going from touting him as
a hero from not cooperating just six
weeks ago to saying Roger stone Roger
stone who he didn't even work for me
anywhere near this campaign so read
between the lines and Roger stone went
from it's all a witch hunt to I'd
cooperate if my lawyers thought that it
was a good idea in the matter of
effectively what is just ours stunning
we are going to follow it and of course
it could be a while until we actually
see what sort of consequences there are
going to be for Roger stone here because
these things don't always take place as
quickly as we might like to see okay I
guess we sort of have to talk about
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Donald Trump's
press secretary uh where to even start
with this on Monday we talked Monday or
Tuesday we talked about how she gave her
first press briefing in 41 days it was
riddled with the same non-answers
deflections and blaming Democrats that
we've seen from her for a very long time
at this point and one of the questions
that I've asked morn
about Sara Huckabee Sanders is why is
she doing this because she's so publicly
lying just endlessly why has she chosen
to do this why does she work for Trump
at all but more importantly why is she
doing something so public she could be
pushing papers for the Trump
administration in some back office but
she's the front and center primary liar
who has to go out there and defend an
obfuscate for Donald Trump's benefit and
I floated a few different ideas about
why she may be doing this one
possibility if she gets paid really well
well we know what she gets paid and it's
a nice Whitehouse top-tier salary but
her father Mike Huckabee has somewhere
around 10 million dollars I don't think
that she has to be doing this job for
the money and she could probably get
another job making a decent salary maybe
not what she makes working at the White
House is it possible that she is a
religious woman and as the daughter of a
preacher or whatever else Mike Huckabee
is that she believes that she is doing
God's work in some way that God has
called her to be press secretary of the
United States maybe now we're sort of
starting to get a little bit closer and
it seems that God is a big part of the
explanation because when you look back
and say wait a second why would a
so-called Christian be so willing to lie
and to distort and to attack reporters
and do everything that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is doing unless she thinks the
big picture is that she's doing God's
work because Trump was appointed by God
for example this was merely hypothetical
until now because Sarah Huckabee Sanders
was interviewed on one of the most
depraved television channels around
Christian Broadcasting Network and she
has confirmed that yes she believes God
wanted Donald Trump to be President take
a look I think God calls all of us to
fill different roles at different times
and I think that he wanted Donald Trump
to become president and that's why he's
there
and I think he has done a tremendous job
and supporting a lot of the things that
people of faith really care about
exactly if it wasn't for God Trump
wouldn't be President that's a very
strange sense of humor for God isn't it
it wasn't Trump's foreign policy it
wasn't Trump's trade ideas it wasn't the
implication that Mexicans are by and
large criminals although some Trump is
sure or good people
God just wanted Trump to be President of
the United States and that that's why
he's there and by extension that is why
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is also there
lying
day in and day out or every 41 days when
she actually does press briefings or
whatever the case may be so what I'm
wondering is is every American president
there because God wanted them to be
because if she believes that God wanted
Trump to be president doesn't it stand
to reason isn't it logically required
that God wanted President Obama to be
President twice rather than just once
except pat we never hear them actually
mentioning that ever in fact we hear
Obama was the Antichrist or Obama is
Satan's or something like that
well God is an independent voter so back
in the 90s he was a Democrat that's why
he pushed for Bill Clinton then in the
you know early 2000s he went Republican
when with George Bush then went back to
Democrat with Obama and now he's here
with Trump I guess God just can't make
up his mind which political party does
he support we may never know it changes
all the time and this sort of gets to
the absurdity of what I discussed with
Arian Foster yesterday which was a
former NFL player Arian Foster said yeah
I never really understood when players
say that they were able that they won
the game because of God who under what
circumstances is God sort of deciding
the outcome of individual NFL football
games along these same lines if you
believe God is picking presidents then
he's picking all of them right including
Barack Obama two times so this is also
crazy I want to zoom out from it a
little bit because there's an important
element to evangelicals here that I
think bears some examination
evangelicals
among other Christians and other
religions but in the United States
evangelicals are some of the loudest
that do exactly what Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is doing they confuse or they
conflate what they want with God's will
I wanted Trump to be President of the
United States and I'm religious and
Trump is president so god wanted it
right I wanted to in the case of George
W Bush I wanted to go to Iraq and I'm a
born-again evangelical Christian so
clearly God told Bush to go into Iraq
it's a combination of a very particular
brand of religious delusion with egoism
in very specific proportions that get
you in your head to believing stuff like
this Trump is there because God wanted
him to be there self-interest is sort of
the focus of their morality and of
course it's ridiculous by its own merits
why would God want the adulteress
cheating lying criminal who was
pro-choice his entire life coming from
people out of money and conning people
out of money is well contractors
customers at Trump University if God is
involved in selecting presidents why on
earth would he pick one that goes so
directly against the gospel that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders claims to follow a
truly disgusting human being
Sarah Huckabee Sanders maybe the worse
than the administration for her role in
the propaganda and our suspicions were
true she is willing to I would guess go
against what her religion teaches her
about lying and honesty and all of that
other stuff because she believes that
the broad strokes the big picture is
that God chose Trump to be President and
therefore her participation in the
administration is in a literal sense
godly it's disgusting and these are the
people that are in charge these are the
agenda setters these are the people who
dis
side they have gatekeeping power to
decide what we know and what don't we
know about what President Trump is doing
we're in real trouble make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman and while you're there follow the
show on instagram as well at david
pakman show